[Applause]
rca
they believe in me and one thing that
rca does which is
great which labels don't do is they
allow artists to be themselves and do
what they want what the [ __ ] they want
to do you know
and um rca allowed me to do what i
wanted with this album
and i didn't get the big label push
on 1984 it's more of like
my [ __ ] but surprisingly i put it out
and it's killing it it's killing and
it's like
the people are losing their minds man
people i mean i feel like it's a
cleansing of
of of uh everyone's palate sonically
we're thinking about that off the camera
just like
with what's going on in the world clubs
aren't going on yeah
there's like people are looking for
like music to sit with exactly like dude
like
if i were to die this [ __ ] would be like
my big one you understand like if i'm
gone
like in no exaggeration if something
happens to me
this album is gonna be legendary classic
timeless iconic
yeah you know what i'm saying and and if
you're not if you don't feel like that
about your project then you shouldn't
put it out
that's fair and this is not me bragging
about me this is me to having
this is me with rolling stone magazine
interviews
uh forbes doing doing some of the
greatest biggest interviews with some of
the most relevant
interviewers of all time that have have
interviewed icons
telling me this is an iconic album so
it's
so the way i feel about it is through
the people telling me not me telling
myself
you know what i'm saying i can't toot my
own horn that only could get me as far
as
getting me somewhere but when the people
that have the right credentials
tell you yo this is this is an
incredible project and
it kind of makes you you know this is
okay
i'm saying stairs album which is my
first one is my
late registration okay or college
dropout i was gonna say that's kanye's
second album but okay no but no
because i have foreplay okay yeah yeah
true true true so that's mine you had a
lot of singles that's what yeah that's
my college dropout for play
and my late registration stairs
and let's just skip a few albums and
um gashy is my graduation this is your
808s this is my 808s
changing changing music exactly waits to
change music
exactly this is my eight oh this is my
eighth away yeah i would say 808 and
yeezys
are two like albums kanye put out that
just sonically changed
like the direction of like hip hop or
music
yeah my my to my doctor was fancy as
well yeah
of course of course i just mean in terms
of like sound sound
yes yes you know what i mean i agree i
agree and uh my next one
my next album is going to be my my um
my mind my doctors to fantasy mine
my version fire and then after that is
going to be
um my jesus and then you don't know
where i'm gonna go with it but i just
the thing is the key is to never make
the same song twice
never make the same sounding album i
always wanted to make my [ __ ] sound
like i want to make when i'm in the
world was
in the theme i'm in the theme my next
project i wanted to feel like 90s dance
music
you know okay like i wanted to feel like
a gay club
like that's how i want my music to feel
like i wanted to feel like
shout out to all my gay fans too like
they shout out you know shout out to all
my gay fans like
like they have some of the most
incredible taste ever
ever and they put me on all the time
like listen to this listen to that
and i kind of like like i like i
appreciate
how like how much love i get from not
from everyone but
so sonically you want to go and like i'm
just when i think of like
what you just said i don't know why
knight of the roxbury just popped in
yeah yeah yeah that's that's true that
now that's roxbury like those kind of
vibes
yeah like you know what i'm saying like
like
ace bro like that's that's the [ __ ]
that's the you can pull the uh
the will pharaoh or what what's the
other guy's name the tiny guy
something can i don't know he's locked
up right yeah oh is he i think so yeah
damn
that'd be cool but man like
bro like we're not here forever man
you know like do what you love bro like
people i swear if you see how fast
people move on
after somebody dies in 2020 you think
twice before thinking about what someone
else is going to say about you